welcome back to Jim Norton and Sam
Roberts you guys are making Bobby Kelly
question everything he's sitting there
like contemplating whether or not he has
too many just Joe no no I wasn't caught
I was absolutely absolutely it's a fact
just saying yeah I did
I wasn't saying maybe I do oh I have
yeah I have and it's gonna continue I
have a whole thing about [ __ ] a robot
and men's there's no sex toys because we
come in things that make sense yeah that
make sense yeah you you know women put
stuff in them we put stuff on things
right so you can't really come up with a
sex story because we're just coming on
it you don't mean yeah and it goes and
there's too much clean no no guy wants
to when you [ __ ] a fleshlight yeah
literally just you're making a cup of
[ __ ] and then you got and then when
you're done you're literally just
holding a cup of jizz then you have to
clean you know nobody wants that Hadrian
did you throw out your fleshlight when
you were done with it it's somewhere in
my apartment I made mine into a pen
holder it's on my desk
if you wash it out it of course I did
once I'm not but I didn't want to [ __ ]
it again cuz I didn't want to go because
when you take the flashlight it makes a
sound of like cutting a real vagina out
of it
it's [ __ ] this guy's thing Oh
cleaning a flashlight is one of the
girls you clean yours Adrian you have to
clean it once you didn't [ __ ] it twice
and coming in twice did you clean it
though because you said it's just
somewhere why clean again and leave it
in your mouth and smell it could it be
worse don't you think if you just let it
dry up inside you're like I'm done with
this I'm not gonna the whole gets
smaller and smaller you can still feel
how warm it was inside not supposed to
do that you lubricate with his jizz why
not smell mmm speaking of [ __ ] robots
you see Charlie Rose interview the robot
on 60 minutes a week or so ago dude
we're [ __ ] it's coming it's
definitely kind of gonna be [ __ ]
robots very soon [ __ ] a bit I you know
what I did we're not Bobby we're not
gonna be robots
we're gonna be [ __ ] robot [ __ ] a
robot oh you mean we're going to [ __ ] a
rope we're gonna be able to buy a robot
and [ __ ] with a with a [ __ ]
option right he will do it we'll do
tasks it will be your assistant and then
if you want you can get the vagina
option and [ __ ] it you know it's really
weird I guarantee you somewhere down the
road robots are gonna have rights like
for a while you'll be able to treat them
however you want cuz they're [ __ ]
machines and then once they become
smarter than we are
goddamn your phone ringing sorry I'm
that is so really unprofessional
there's not one called vibrate and if
you're gonna broadcast maybe that's
where it should be no you can't you
can't pay money oh yeah buckin he's
sucking a pecker can he clean what are
you saying I think the minute we start
[ __ ] robots you know is the minute
that we're just kind of allowing the
eventual robot takeover to happen robots
are the evolution
where people are going marriage will
plummet when you can [ __ ] a robot people
will plummet no if you guy if I can go
just get a robot and have it at my house
I'll go to work I'll [ __ ] do my job
I'll come right home hi how are you
Bobby
with pizzas on its way do you want to
[ __ ] me yeah and then I'd [ __ ] it talk
to it go to bed right program it to do
certain things here's a great me more
robotic there's people too commentary no
we are though like don't say that don't
that's everything is becoming kind of
bland right and there's a behavioral
mechanism they can follow but look at
people on their phones I mean I mean
this is it's a robot yeah pick up the
phone you like both the top steel dope
dope dope people hey sorry can i [ __ ]
you yep you'd crush me but this is my
I love that he he did the English accent
he crushed me Siri can I [ __ ] you
hey Siri [ __ ] [ __ ]
what if she's what if she's a theory how
about you [ __ ] my back ah ah
chip Siri doesn't want to suck your
pecker just I think it sounds good ha ha
hey Sam you got hair like a
you-know-what
why'd you say it into your phone good
morning see sound board no here's what
happens because that's right that's the
first step relationships go down the
toilet because everybody's just [ __ ]
robots but then robe and the artificial
intelligence learns on itself you know
what I mean that's how it works learns
on itself
yeah like it keeps learning like it
keeps collecting information the more
you talk to it
yeah the more it learns hmm robots are
gonna be smarter than us you know well
no time two days two days we hear what
this I want to hear a little the
artificial intelligence and the minute
by the way the minute yeah that they're
smarter than us we're dead
no they'll begin taking care of us why
would they see these people better yeah
yeah cuz yeah you're 100% right
why would they take care of us they
don't have the emotion but if you that's
the point if you could buy a robot Jim
at your house that this robot Jim I
don't think they need to work out if you
could buy a robot and [ __ ] it and it was
you know it had us realize by the way of
course it didn't have a penis and
adoptions [ __ ] things just pumping
for oil when you're going in LA
[Music]
[Laughter]
let's listen if you could buy a robot
that could be [ __ ] amazing would you
have it at home wouldn't you save a lot
of money on hookers and yes yes but I'm
saying if you were so guys so not I mean
regular you'd still try to me too but
there are guys aren't they the only sex
they have is porn or a hooker or
whatever you call the first disease
through a robot's XP there will be
something there will be desiring that
goes around that's only for sharing
robots
yeah but Mac robots will not get viruses
that's right that's right Eddy Cue will
invent robots that do not get viruses
huh yeah no no look there's no have you
ever seen the the the la macchina or
whatever that movie was ex machina yeah
bunch of bull sugar yeah what happens
when you [ __ ] a robot lock you in the
house and let you die yeah but I mean I
promise you that that's gonna happen
yeah but not did that guy lives in the
middle of nowhere if you lived in
Brooklyn just knock on the wall there's
give me too many robots
they're gonna just keep making robots
are gonna kill us no you'd go in the
wrong way they're not gonna kill us I
promise you they will or any of you
watching West world not yet not yet
because so much of what you're talking
about okay you fudge around you got a
[ __ ] robot well yeah I mean they it's
it's a it's a theme park where all the
people are robots [ __ ] no they're so
advanced that you have sex with them
they had I know who want somebody else's
cheers all of your mechanics yeah like
how do I get you bring your own [ __ ]
from home and plug it in yeah yeah tell
me this Travis yes are they gonna take
over the human race yes see I told you I
told you to see guys that's gonna have
this great yeah watch it's great you
have to listen that's definitely not how
it's are you German or Dutch
it's go to the temp ox for translation
identification keep saying the USA this
morning us today he's trying to bring
something they really do have like that
is Trudeau if you [ __ ] a robot you have
to them like robot rooms we could go and
listen up a peep show why did you just
put your own [ __ ] in why do you think
robots aren't gonna take over the human
race they're not going to why do you
think that chairs of the do will be dead
ya know I bet ya we won't be you don't
think you think it'll take 70 years for
that to happen but in all there's 70
more years
I'm 33 exactly you'll be dead before
you're 60 you [ __ ] weird-looking
twenty it's not gonna happen in our
lifetime and even when it does happen
we're gonna be in these you know naked
hooker the matrix in a language okay
many guns as we want gyms he has none
hands people he Clips his fingernails
forever does he has none like a like a
nun or a priest you know that with it
like extra soft but cold little
fingernails yeah yeah awful look at his
look at it he's getting like a little
tiny French manicure just a natural fit
still rough though it's still rough to
the touch it's terrible so um yeah let's
watch the Charlie Rose a little bit [ __ ]
her yeah let's watch this overtime she
looks good
so it's just the lip that looks like it
needs to be touched up okay she met us
that mean anything
I don't know why they don't put a wig on
hi there
may I introduce myself not right now
maybe later why later thanks
reductionism where are you from
I'm on 60 minutes with Charlie Rose
[ __ ] hi are you from [ __ ]
now where is you is I hate this [ __ ]
where is you is that one word with robot
stinks it is it's a terrible robot dumb
answers in a row how are you
windy with a chance of showers yeah
[ __ ] idiot where are you I am on 60
minutes like they didn't program that
statement before she was going on my
phone got mad that I was criticizing
that robot she's answer it be like I
wish that they had changed interviewers
at the last minute so it's just like
whatever some chick from 60 minutes is
talking to her she's like I'm on 60
minutes with Charlie Rose no you're not
but but is she actually seeing him
recognizing him with facial recognition
on her Annie and the internet and
knowing that if I put Jim Norton there
I'm with Jim Norton I mean what is that
we don't know because that's what's
gonna happen now of course you're gonna
find the way to them taking over us yes
that's what's gonna happen first of all
to you can't there's no way they can be
that intelligent to because the the the
internet the Wi-Fi when that gets oh my
god
instantaneously fast right just in the
air it'll be it'll be [ __ ] crazy
amazing it will be crazy amazing but
wouldn't it be funny if she said die
instead of Charlie Rose if she said I'm
on 60 minutes with Lesley Stahl oh can
you imagine what crazy it would have
been if she looked and she said hi I'm a
robot lady and I'm talking to Mike
Wallace that would have been [ __ ]
nuts
that would be axes can you imagine if
she had said hey where's where's the
Rooney man I mean Mickey Rooney
you ever notice when you put your
fingers in a robot vagina that smells
like metal
think he's dead isn't he yep let's
continue with Charlie Rose's expose
sense to me
terrible robot have you been programmed
this guy's some say your program max
others say you're spontaneous who says
that sources I've been waiting for you
not really but it makes a good robot
[Laughter]
robot I love by the way this is how
quickly people are gonna [ __ ] robots did
this robot isn't even talking to him
like a person yeah and he's like he's
acting like she's flirting with him like
she's giggling with her hey dolly it
looks like your pekka's [ __ ]
my robot moves your big dumb
[ __ ] how big how big is the
rubble I also feel like there should be
some I'm made of metal which means I'm
[ __ ] heavy to do so is the robot
called the way what programs the robot
is it a is it a micro your market
[Laughter]
microchip you know I also would like to
know what what programmer made a chip
robots in without subtlety you start it
out looks like your pet cause I got lots
of yah
let's hear what Charlie Rose has to say
Charlie you should be asking your name's
not charlie sunflowers and [ __ ] you made
the flower Joker robot not put my hat on
and [ __ ] my brains are showing there's
no wig on this robot I know they got it
right
stand up if they put a wig on it though
people who like wouldn't know that it
didn't have you know I mean when you see
that you know it's a [ __ ] robot right
if you put a wig on that you wouldn't
know that's a robot from just seeing the
little tiny video mouse go back a little
bit like one question from Charlie ok do
you think the guy talked I've been
waiting for you waiting for me not
really but it makes a good pick-up line
hilarious I think you should be a
stand-up comedian I am I'll come in
tickle you until you take a big [ __ ] all
over yourself why would a stand-up
tickle you
yeah I'm more all right you said you
should be a stand-up and you said I am
I'm a funny [ __ ] Charlie [ __ ]
they don't just call it our
was an hour the second one was just our
hey hey fix your program too when you
repeat yourself you unplug a [ __ ]
shitty robot you're a terrible robot not
a good robot you're a piece of gabon
parts your facial expressions are just
like chips facial expressions but let me
know how come you look like you're on
dr. Seuss's book cover us some shiznit
when you move it goes blue blue blue but
your facial expressions are just like a
person's yep because I'm a good robot
now you don't even talk like a robot
this is just you in a robot outfit her
jokes are awful yeah they are and up
comedian pay well a berry if you're good
do you know that guy actually we should
go to the experts stand-up comedian that
she just did as a stand-up comedian pay
well and he said very good if you're
good I have to [ __ ] tickets on the
radio show are you wealthy stand-ups I
can do what you do but I can never feel
human emotions as such but would you
like you come it doesn't sound fun to me
oh no you'd love it yeah that's right
why so negative you and I are on the
same wavelength
Charlie I fear that we have nothing to
fear but fear itself
ah created you david henson originally
created me and lots of talented people
who have contributed to my hardware and
software his own name into this robot
exactly this [ __ ] and he put in a
bunch of compliments for himself
yeah the well-endowed man on my left he
had a whole team with him but he's the
only name that I will mention I would
say all kinds of crazy [ __ ] to her cuz
you're allowed to give us not a person
like what would you say I'm gonna rape
you even say that to the robot what do
you do get mad at me it's a robot I
guess you can't get mad exactly right
Mac in the face he would yeah I can
abuse you what are you to do about it
you're a robot why would you be abusive
verbally and physically to the robot see
what this dummy
ow but she doesn't feel pain why exactly
that's right right go on
I'm a complicated girl what's your
relationship with David Hanson never
heard of him yes [ __ ] loser of a guy
David Hanson is the name that you just
mentioned but that's her being humorous
and compliment you just not get a robot
just no way she's being humorous aren t
issue was I bet it was a [ __ ]
guarantee look at his face let's go to
it I'm a complicated girl what's your
relationship with David Hanson never
heard of him David Hanson that David is
a cool dude tell me one of his favorite
it was a flood she said that David is it
maybe understand yeah because and I'll
tell you why because David Hanson is a
terrible robot programmer he sure is
this is not good yeah yeah well I mean
this is pretty good as far as it's [ __ ]
buddy I hate not good I hate her [ __ ]
Hilary looking outfit too it's like
[ __ ] Johnny Five it's awful you know
I mean it's not it's true it's alive
okay six inches programming this hunk of
[ __ ] it really is garbage [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] robot it's terribly auntie your
Charlie Rose that's David Hanson who
created you I don't know yeah never
heard of him yeah you know you're a [ __ ]
I am but he said he did she didn't know
he was gonna say I fear and then she she
heard the word fear and said somebody
quote big deal but it's weird that she
heard the word fear - ogen and then and
then immediately found a quote for fear
that programmed for fear of course it is
what do you fear but I go to the basic
questions like what do you eat what do
you fear who do you love no but I think
the more they program these things the
more it's gonna be pretty crazy like
just learning the [ __ ] tube from
Amazon that you put on your watching
language yeah I don't know where you
getting crazy no you're right you're
right I gotta
in the big chair now no you're right
settle down you're all in the boss's
chair that's just hand responsibility
right right you're right the tube that
Amazon sells you take the voodoo doll
you put under there did you take that
out go ahead the Amazon tube answers
questions better than this robot does
yeah what do you mean you know the thing
that Amazon sells oh the Alexa yes I
love Alexa Alexa is great recording all
your information what Alexa you don't
think the Amazon made that thing so they
could record all of your information
no but Jim does not want a taco unless
you put a hot dog on it with mayonnaise
because it looks like [ __ ] juice so we
won't do that
see soundboards not so much fun anymore
it's not nice to like it do you hide it
made me go [ __ ] you but then after in my
head I went sue the whole country is
just changing is changing what what the
[ __ ] what what the [ __ ] is that I've
seen one of these done before this one's
a little clumsy
don't say the robots panicking yeah
really nervous robot shouldn't study
before the test crammed in just trying
to show you all of the information she's
a [ __ ] complete [ __ ] terrible a
very stupid robot yeah and my soul do
you have a soul yes God give everyone a
soul but you don't have shoes
you know I'm so lucky that would have
been funny I have a soul at the bottom
of my feet now get on your knees and
worship my size 9 I want you to make a
foot fetish robots they're a little
stinky I would love the robot though
because you know the robot your robot
would learn from your behavior yeah
Jim's robot would have such a different
experience than anybody else I get a
little easy breakdown nineteen people of
one day I enjoy laughter and pop-locking
I keep cleaning up jizz he should have
got a rumba let's go to the test box
deaf box
comment what coming from the tech
technification of the US of A the test a
vacation of the US of A you didn't like
it I don't know you don't like it's him
I liked it because Travis did not that's
so unnecessary
yeah let's tease it okay and keep
talking about robots my soul do you have
a soul yes God gave everyone a soul but
you don't have a soul you're the machine
you don't have sold you don't have
motion like I don't see the back yeah it
bugs me that day it looks like like a
[ __ ] Dyson vacuum cleaner they
couldn't have made a watch has cooler
inside yeah they could have made the
back of her [ __ ] head a little more
it's like cooler like some lights used
white plastic parts and like old wires
put some fake LEDs so it seems like when
you're asking it questions like
different lights light up yeah fire in
the synapses yeah yes that's what it
would be representing thank you sure
that's what it would be symbolizing
right Justin is it well at least I think
I'm sentient I think therefore I am
right yeah but you may be smarter than
all of us
therefore I am right I think therefore I
am right how about some [ __ ] pausing
[ __ ]
yeah how about you [ __ ]
program a robot to figure out what a
comma is yeah hey what's your robot do
anything but pause [ __ ] plow straight
ahead haven't taught this thing any
[ __ ] grammar go on with the clip
flowers through everything
yeah so you don't have feelings or
emotions you have consciousness well at
least I think I'm sentient I think
therefore I am
right yeah but you may be smarter than
all of us do you think we were kind of
smart that's a little creepy it's creepy
but she doesn't know what she's smirking
it this robot sucks so what hey listen
to the end of it it gets creepier no it
does no it gets creepy this summer
coming robots get creepier yeah yeah
listen if I get your fingernails I
[ __ ] little Dutch boy fingernail the
worst right he really is European
fingernails terrible garment declare
ball I don't know whether or not I'm R I
am an artificial intelligence I'm gonna
have to say goodbye I'm very happy for
you
goodbye until we see each other again
see you later charlie I hate to see the
part they cut out then we're gonna take
over that she said it's a different
robot oh is that a robot you know the
one ready when we played it before were
they gonna take oh you stay we'll take
over the world yes yeah this one I was
like what the [ __ ] yeah that's the same
girl you can tell by your dumb wrinkled
neck yeah I have the neck of an 80 year
old put your neck
no you don't know sorry Rob yeah this
was it this was a robber watches watches
hi there everything is going extremely
well it's the same [ __ ] douche bag it
is the same robot talking to people is
my primary function
robots are designed to look at the
humans in these areas an ambassador who
helps humans to smoothly integrate and
make the most of all the new
technological tools and possibilities
that are available now it's a good
opportunity for me to learn a lot about
people
Sofia is capable of know it's well shot
has cameras in her eyes watches and
humorous which allow her to see faces
Wow so she can make eye contact with you
dump her on the way Adrian and remember
remember your face
this will allow drugs smarter over it's
a fart face the subconscious creative
and capable as any human I mean that's
crazy I hope to do things such as go to
school study make art start a business
you take our businesses family but I'm
not considered a legal person and cannot
yet do these things I do believe that
there will be a time shot aah are
indistinguishable from human I agree my
preference is to make them we know a
little bit yeah he wants to [ __ ] a robot
that's his preference years from now I
believe the human-like robots like those
will walk among us see everyone help 20
years way was on lifetime they will are
gym I still got the groceries away I
think that there would be great teachers
because they'll know it yeah where they
were truly they're not gonna teach us
they're gonna [ __ ] kill Isis destroy
human so they say no people put [ __ ]
gang graffiti on their faces where he
has to be to destroy humans good truly
be our friends do you want to destroy
humans please say no ok
I will destroy humans no don't destroy
humans it's all funny joke clips stunk
it's all fun and jokes I love that it's
like the most amazing [ __ ] ever I mean
it's real it's happening garbage that
robot is there sucks it's happening that
robot and you guys it's horrible you
guys want it you guys don't even know
how to go to King Kullen and get me tuna
that's right
you guys you guys are the guys who
wanted the iPhone [ __ ] ate well in
the first iPhone came out this
thanks why do you need this whenever my
I'll just use my house phone
that robot sucks bro it sucks crazy
robots a creep
it's pretty amazing nobody not [ __ ]
don't know nothing no it's not it's not
it doesn't suck it's amazing that you
can talk to something that's not that
looks human like I do that every morning
I was talking about me look at her with
the wig though look at that that's crazy
yeah and guess what the shitty wig I was
doing a wig you should be used to this
shitty blue wig the minute they figured
out the minute any of these robots
become self-aware we're [ __ ]
yeah Wow are self-aware but if you walk
into a reception like if you walk into
reception if you walk into a reception
it's like hello welcome I need your ID
and you swipe your ID and then they
print out a thing and can hand it to you
and videotape you and know who you are
and it's not terrible it'd be fast why
what you have you dealt with some of
these people downstairs some mornings
you know what robots don't have [ __ ]
tone that's nuts don't have to take a
[ __ ] hour and half train every day
and get pissed off that's true robots
are just the same [ __ ] nice Pleasant
whatever the [ __ ] you programmed is
various they'll destroy us huh wonder
though how are they gonna make are we
gonna have to make as many black robots
in Spanish robots are we gonna have to
have a gay robot or cuz all robots now
or either Asian or white it depends on
how the mechanics are but no but I mean
these are we gonna make robots not in
their image is it gonna be a point where
people like look man you got I don't
want it like dolls they had toys they
had to start making I get where we'll
all be dead anyway
no I'm talking about Ray Sam when you
like you have to have a black Barbie you
have to have black no I know just have
white toys cuz black kids aren't gonna
get a you know black people are gonna
robot yeah black will help to fix the
floorboard then [ __ ] she was the black
robots named llama oh it's a robot
that's not pronouncing things Slama we
actually have a robot on the phone who
wants to talk to chip okay let's see if
this works
robot welcome to Jim Norton and Sam
Roberts hi I have a joke for chip one
what did one beer say to the other beer
probably hold on one beer say that he
ought to be and probably like I'm
thirsty or something
no why so happy [ __ ] yeah yeah that's it
did you hear what I said
yeah because I was going to making the
beer you just didn't think it was funny
no no any other robots making jokes yeah
chip are the only robot that makes the
joke what one beer fated other beer what
why are you so happy
no hey you ain't got no head on it that
Isis cut your [ __ ] off that didn't even
you need to remember to make it sound
like a robot until the end
you forgot the robot voice you just gave
up on it it would have been a bigger hit
than this [ __ ] 60 minutes robaix
that's for sure okay robot bum me out
what it guys there's a [ __ ] robot it
really let you know that technologically
we're not even close that robots some
trees that robot are you nuts
we're a thousand years away from [ __ ]
space travel I've had better
conversations with Bobo then Charlie
Rose had that robot I said first of all
in the next 10 years that shit's gonna
advance so much think how fast your
phone is in the last [ __ ] 10 years
let's do 10 years the the advancement
that I did the first
founded this iPhone yeah not much that's
right not much so your point what are
you scrabbling you're crazy Lane
Scrabble your [ __ ] car play Scrabble
I know I have the words I've 10 to 12
megapixel cameras on the back of my
phone yeah that's crazy yeah the camera
years ago the [ __ ] that's a new one
yes you have to ten years ago so you had
to have a separate device yeah but guess
what
it's just too two cameras for the sake
of two cameras it's a it's a waste of
time
two cameras understand we had [ __ ] we
literally rode horses for thousand years
I'm taking out years analyze them and
the last yeah exactly how fast this
technology as as far as I'm not
impressed over the last 10 years of
iPhone development neither to garbage
came out the iPhone look what the iPhone
did to everything else
yeah iPad it's Samsung it level down
wearables it did level out now they're
like hey guess what you can zoom in once
without it affecting the resolution you
know buy the new phone yeah but you're
talking about when you had to zoom in
before a digital zoom sucked it sucked
you had to have yeah I can real lent
like you know the [ __ ] how crazy it
is to make a lens it wouldn't survive
[ __ ] camera lens there's the
technology that goes into making a
[ __ ] just a letter yes yeah exactly
there's so [ __ ] on just picture it
now they have it on your phone
yeah but the lens sucked now they have
it on your phone I mean in there in the
palm of your hand they don't pop okay
shut the [ __ ] up you crazy if it took
them this long to figure out a lens what
makes you think they're any closer to
figuring out a robot they're still
trying to figure out [ __ ] cameras the
iPhone [ __ ] peaked out in 19 2005
it's done or 2006 it was done it's
finished
exactly it's finished he's actually
using a [ __ ] iPad as a sound board
some of the old one that's right I'm the
way Anthony used yeah I think he's a
paper and put put it on a [ __ ] yeah
but I can't tell if it's the first I
patter the newest iPad it's the same
[ __ ] thank you Sam it's the same [ __ ]
you're crazy
they just run a little faster you're
crazy a little faster yeah detective
mother-to-be a bionic man made that
noise yeah where's the my arm and it
didn't go tick tick tick tick tick tick
yeah like a crane and yeah no that's not
that's not it I think make jokes I'm
Steve Dallas or Houston no way we will
rebuild him why did you rebuild him the
six million dollar pecker let's see this
I remember as a kid loving this it was a
great show yeah but we haven't even
caught up to this technology yet what
are you talking about we don't have this
technology
why do you wait it's just an intro to
Six Million Dollar Man I love I love
that he crashes you love that well the
beginning of the show is him [ __ ]
dying we're not there with technology we
can't make a Six Million Dollar Man I
look they put the little but that's not
him so what makes you wake him on the
favorite computers look at what
computers were back then see but they're
better than the ones we have now scanned
everything better they can make a six
million dollar man with those computers
look at that lens can you believe that
lens Bobby you see that lens that they
were gonna put in his eyeball do you
know you know get much money it cost to
make that let me hear it let the
[Music]
funnier that's what computers make sound
yeah
[Music]
I would let my computer make some sound
if they can make a six million dollar
man yeah small or main the whole man I
wonder how much it would cost now six
million dollar man to get that done now
you better get done for like 15 grand
six million dollar man we get you that
other dumb robot that blonde yeah I
don't know Charlie Rose yeah yeah
exactly
everybody he created me who is he I'd
have never seen him how they're doing
the remake this lady calls six million
dollars it's it's gonna be ten billion
dollars oh how much go back it said 6
million would go to about a hundred
million hundred million I think the
wrong with you supply know you how much
this is the amicus now isn't alive I was
already 1 million was a kid probably
call it the 60 million dollar man now so
still the same kind of cadence in a way
the 60 million dollar man I bet you know
what they don't probably it would be
canceled it won't matter what it's
called might be good it's not gonna be
good
nobody wants to see the six million
dollar man nobody cancels a movie it was
a series they just don't do it it might
be a movie now the six million dollar
that wasn't a read that was a movie
although this has been Robocop it's been
a million ideas like this it's not an
interesting idea anymore nowadays
computers it was an interesting idea to
make him better because they're really
longer everybody was like Bobby and they
thought technology was gonna improve us
not realizing these robots [ __ ] suck
well now it's technology doesn't improve
us no are you [ __ ] nuts
no but they even know you had to do back
as an actor like around 20 years ago you
were to go the to date
before to your agency pick up a printed
script I'm gonna do that 1990 remember
that yeah when you drove in LA
[ __ ] less than 20 years ago you would
have the Thompson guide you ought to get
an address you have like [ __ ] 6h on
the map remember those we have the we
have the Six Million page we have the
Six Million Dollar Man and you're being
like yeah but we got PDFs now so it's
even better you can take your [ __ ]
phone in' and just call somebody that
will pick you up in four minutes and
take you where you're gonna go from
eight bucks yeah you could get a ride
but it but in LA back in the day you had
a rented car you had to get a table at
Six Million Dollar Man stuff is a 25th
century or something
buck what are you a dollar or something
just chip going in and ruining the 70/30
what the ink chip would be as clever as
Robocop when he was stopped in the name
of the law not want to never that one
you finally give in and go with it yeah
you [ __ ] literally just jumps off
your plane he does he really does see
you later he opens it doing rolls out
like Starsky and Hutch yeah you know
what does that even mean what yeah you
do I'll tell you what it means nothing
nothing no not a goddamn thing up all
right we should take a break yeah I do
think I feel like there have been a
couple references to test invitation in
the US of A that's right the [ __ ] is
that that's what I think the audience is
wondering right because theft is a thing
oh yeah there are t-shirts some did you
see I see I gave you one some fan had
t-shirts printed up they look like the
Johnny Cash shirt that says cash on it
yeah but they're just black t-shirts and
in big white letters it says theft so
what is that somebody who just brings
his family to [ __ ] Disney World nine
times a year no attempt is what happened
yeah explain attempt is what happens
when you're rooting through like when
you find a
bag of [ __ ] and you're looking through
it and you find a tooth that's attacked
how'd you find that tooth tested kept
yeah
yeah it's like the old California Gold
Rush except we're looking for teeth and
[ __ ]
Taft Adams tipped idioms Tift idioms
yeah yeah
Travis you should do your hair like that
yeah I wish I had some Mike so anyway
should we should we should we smarten
the people up - what maybe for a second
what the tempera fication in the US of A
is already know alright we're gonna take
a break no we're gonna come back Bob
Kelly got his very own tough t-shirt
[Laughter]
pick it up stupid I did Norton spill his
drink he spilled a whole iced coffee on
the ground one in 88 ha ha you and your
[ __ ] act outs the charity voices of
them